[Music]
all right people
this is the reuben report direct message
and according to the paperwork i was
just handed i am
dave rubin all right very exciting uh
today
is a big day we've got three stories for
you today
that we went through last night i was
like you know what let's see if we can
get a little ahead of the game let's see
what's happening
uh the day before we do our tuesday show
this week let's see if we can just find
some things and then i always say to my
guys but because
it's not just that we live in a 24-hour
news cycle anymore we more
so live in a every second news cycle i
was like you know
something might happen in the morning
and we're going to have to adjust
the stories accordingly so i don't know
if you heard about this
but apparently at this very moment
within the last hour it's all happening
right now
donald trump president trump i know some
people think he's not the president or
he's not their president or something
like that apparently he's still the
president for everybody
uh he is at the white house uh with the
israeli prime minister
and uh people from the united arab
emirates and the kingdom
of bahrain and they've just signed this
massive
peace deal so this wasn't even one of
the stories i wanted to cover today i do
want to just talk about it
briefly uh and then we'll move on and
obviously
this is going to be an ongoing thing up
until election day and then and then
we'll have repercussions
far past election day but there is
something
absolutely massive
that cannot be overstated happening in
the world right now
uh as i said last week it's like i
thought the thing that we all wanted it
didn't matter
if you were a democrat or a republican
or a liberal or a conservative i thought
we all wanted middle east peace right
like what's the thing that none of us
can have
but everyone can agree that peace in the
middle east right that
that seems like a good thing we all seem
to want it we always talk about it that
goes across
uh political spectrum right whether you
you like peace or not everyone seems to
want it
uh well it seems to actually be
happening it has started
with this united arab emirates uh israel
deal now the kingdom of bahrain
there are rumors that now this could be
announced with saudi arabia and some of
the other gulf states like this is this
is
incredible stuff now i get it you might
hate trump
you may not like the hare again you
don't like the way he tweets all of
those things
but there's something actually
incredible happening i think there is a
shift
happening in the world and it's it's a
little it can be uncomfortable
i get it like we know the world in a
certain way there are certain things in
a weird way
it's like if there isn't peace then we
know the world right oh well that it's
just the middle east there's no peace
there
these people hate each other they're
always going to hate each other they're
always fighting blah blah
and then it's like oh well we know
something for a fact and
in a weird way these days we don't know
a lot of things
for a fact right it seems like facts are
constantly being debated i
i always say there's a there's a war uh
for reality happening right now
i believe this you believe this reality
is probably somewhere in between
and it's very hard to ascertain what
that is these days so in a weird way i
think a lot of people
right now you're seeing a huge amount of
support for this deal it's incredible it
seems absolutely incredible to me
hopefully i can get some experts on
uh to talk about it in the next couple
weeks but then you're seeing other
people that sort of
aren't excited because either it's
associated with trump or they're so
invested
in the old world and i think that that's
one of the shifts that we're
we're having right now you know if you
think back to the beginnings of the
lockdown
even related to covet and all that one
of the things that i was talking about
and i heard some other people saying
similar things
was that the old world is ending like
now that we're like six
seven months into this thing doesn't it
feel like february was a lifetime ago
doesn't it feel like
february is the old world it feels like
the old world when you used to go out to
a restaurant with a friend
and not have to wear a mask when you're
in a supermarket and i think
related to this middle east thing it's
like a lot of people don't want to let
go of the old world
now that doesn't mean that the new world
is automatically good right i mean
this is always what my problem with
progressives are you can't just be for
progress you have to be for progressing
towards something that's more just more
more
uh based in true equality and things of
that nature
but you also can't just hold on to the
things because that's how you know how
the world is
and i think a lot of people right now
especially the the trump deranged people
or a lot of the people that were part of
the obama administration and the rest of
it you're seeing their tweets right now
it's like they're not they don't seem to
be for middle east peace and in a weird
way
it's not just because it's trump that's
helping deliver it it's also because
they were invested in an
old world in an old fight and sometimes
you got to let go of some of the old
stuff so you can
build some new stuff so anyway it's just
an absolutely incredible thing and i
watch a little bit of the speeches
right before and and who knows it
doesn't mean
you know just because you sign the paper
that you're gonna have
peace all the time and and nothing bad
will happen and there won't be
negative elements in any if not all of
the societies that will try to try to
rip up those documents
but there's trade there's travel it's
something new
is starting and one of the reasons that
i'm not one of the hysterical people
right now
relative to the entire world is that i
think there's a chance to
to write a new future to blaze a new
path
and i think a lot of us are doing it a
lot of us are doing it and i think if
you're watching this hopefully you're
one of the people that
that sees that and you're willing to go
oh i knew the world a certain way before
this
but now i know it a different way and
and and that could be pretty good too so
peace in the middle east again people i
don't want to be controversial here i
try not to be
very controversial but peace in the
middle east i think it's a good thing
uh but as i said before that was not one
of the three stories we planned on doing
today we will be touching it obviously
over the next couple weeks
uh the three stories that i wanted to
get to uh
two of them are sort of related uh and
then one of them's cobid related first
off
uh i'll start with this story out of the
university
of chicago because this is this is so
depressing in light of what's been
happening to all of our universities and
from university of chicago specifically
so university of chicago
has done one of the best jobs of
defending free speech
on college campuses it's pointed to by
many
academics and many political people and
everything else says oh
you guys are exaggerating that free
speech is being slammed on college
campuses because look at the university
of chicago they've issued this statement
they did this
a while back almost two years ago i
think issued a statement in defense of
free speech their president
has spoken out in defense of free speech
many times
they seem to have done things correctly
that's the way it's been going for the
last two or three years at the
university
of chicago as a matter of fact on the
website of the university of chicago
there is a six minute about a six and a
half minute video
where the president of the university
talks about
why the defense of free speech is so
intrinsic to their university and should
be
an intrinsic value of all universities
of all places of higher education so
we're going to show you just 30 seconds
just the first
30 seconds of that video just to show
you that this is a place where it was
working
they were doing the right thing and as
you can probably tell there's a butt
coming
but first let's just take a look 30
seconds this is on the university of
chicago website
their defense of free speech
the university of chicago started unlike
many universities
as a research university from the very
beginning
this meant that people came here because
they wanted to be
in a serious intellectual environment
that would produce ideas of lasting
importance and value
since its inception the university of
chicago has believed
the most empowering education takes
place in this environment
of open discourse and free expression
this stamped the university of chicago
and has
lasted until the present day
okay so the video goes on for
another six minutes or so and it's a lot
of that it's a lot of we will defend
free speech
it's a lot of this is the purpose of why
we're here
it's a lot of this is why universities
exist so you can exchange ideas you can
become
on you can become comfortable with
thoughts that maybe you are
uncomfortable with
you can learn from people who maybe know
a little bit more about you
and the only way you can do that is with
a robust
defense of free speech so this is
exactly why university of chicago
has been appropriately lauded for their
defense of free speech
and uh that was all good
i said there was a butt coming and i
just said was in the previous sentence
so here's the but
and the was because now the university
of chicago's
english department says it will only
accept
applicants who work in black studies
let me just say that again very clearly
and then i'm going to read their
statement
the university of chicago's english
department
says it will only accept applicants
who will work in black studies and let
me just read the statement for you
because it pretty much stands
on its own for the 2020 2021
graduate admissions cycle the university
of chicago english department is
accepting
only applicants interested in working
in and with black studies english as a
discipline has a long history of
providing aesthetic rationalizations
for colonization exploitation extraction
and anti-blackness our discipline
is responsible for developing
hierarchies of cultural
production that have contributed
directly to social
and systemic determinations of whose
lives matter
and why that ladies and gentlemen
is a load of bunk um you can see
why this is not a place that will be
defending free speech anymore they have
decided that they will only accept
applicants a department the english
department in the university
is saying we're only interested in
having you as part of our graduate
program
if you study this now let's let's try a
different version of this
imagine if the statement that i read to
you was that the university of chicago's
english department says it will only
accept
applicants who will work in white
studies
what would be the word that people would
call that there's a word
racist right that would be racist uh we
will only accept
applicants who will work in asian
studies
what we will only accept applicants who
work in jewish studies in muslim studies
any of these things
these these are this is a crazy an
absolutely crazy premise and it brings
me to something that
that i've talked a bunch about and i
usually hit this on twitter more
i addressed it yesterday um but one of
the things that a few of the names that
you guys know of
that have been attacking social justice
i think in the most effective ways so
uh james lindsey and peter bogosian
uh gad sad there's a couple other people
one of the things that they've all been
talking about
and i've been talking about as well is
that once social
justice enters into an institution
it automatically destroys that
institution and i think that this is a
perfect example of it
because the university of chicago
offered as i said a robust defense of
free speech
now the english department is saying we
will only accept
applicants who want to study this
specific thing
you want to study something else you're
not welcome here
well now they've let that into the
system and once that get in gets into
the system do you think it's only going
to stay
in the english department no it's going
to leak into the sociology department
it's going to leak into all of the other
departments it'll leak into the stem
departments and everything else
and it will take down the university
check what happened
at evergreen state we know this and it's
not just
places of higher education although
you'd have to be high to think you're
getting an education there
uh it's not just places of higher
education because we know this is what
happens
at all of the companies that do this and
this is why the phrase go
woke go broke seems to work because espn
lets
social justice into their network right
which is supposed to be about
sports and next thing you know they're
giving
uh who's the trans give me the trans
woman the trans woman that was part of
the kardashians whatever the hell her
name is
she's getting the espy can i get her
name michael get me her name the trans
woman who
who won the espy uh what's her name
uh jenner kalyn jenner caitlyn jenner
right
so hard to keep up with all of these
people caitlyn jenner
wins the espy for like athlete of the
year a couple weeks
a couple years ago and it's like
nobody's against bruce jenner
now calling himself caitlyn jenner no
one's against trans people
blah blah blah but now you're making
your sports network about things that
have very little to do with sports
that's why this thing will infect all of
the hosts and destroy them from the
inside
but but there's even something more to
that which is once
once you allow this bad set of ideas
to creep into everything you then are
off mission right so like whatever your
business
is let's say your business is making
widgets you make widgets
for the big machines that use widgets
okay
well what you want to do as a widget
company is make the best widget possible
and you don't care
if the guy making the widget is black or
white or gay or straight or anything
else
but once you let in social justice and
you say you know we do need a certain
amount of black widget makers and we
need a certain amount of lesbian
widget makers and a certain amount of
this widget maker or that widget maker
you've now taken your eye off the ball
and you're starting to put attention
on things that don't deserve attention
on top of the fact that you're also
going to then suddenly be welcoming
lawsuits
and all sorts of people who will import
grievance culture into your organization
so the reason that i thought this story
was so important was
that if you're watching this and you
still think
that this thing is only on college
campuses
well i think there's very few people who
think that at this moment because now
we're seeing it leak out into every part
of society
but even chicago university university
of chicago which was one of the few
places that was offering
any last defense on this even they will
now crumble because of this
and we'll see what i think will be
interesting now
is it's on you university of chicago
president
it's on you because now you were the one
you did the talk in that video that we
just played right you've
you've written out your statement of
principles of how you're going to defend
free speech now a defense of free speech
wouldn't be saying
we only want you in the english
department if you want to study black
studies
that's not a defense of free speech
that's that's a assault on free speech
um so now it's on you and we will now
see
an administrator fight the faculty and
and we need all these fights you know
when i started talking about the middle
east peace thing what i was talking
about was the old
world versus the new world well in this
new world we're going to need
administrators
to be fighting faculty we're going to be
needing donors
to either cut money or put money into
certain universities to fight all this
stuff so it's a depressing story in a
certain way
but if the university actually
fights it then maybe something good will
happen i am not going to hold my breath
and i wouldn't recommend that you hold
your breath either all right so
the second story i wanted to cover is
sort of an offshoot of that because it
is
it is related to black lives matter and
how the wider movement
related to all of this is actually
disintegrating all of the societal norms
that we have um and with that old world
new world thing in mind it's like it
doesn't mean that everything we've
always had here is perfect now it's been
pretty
freaking good and in 200 you know 50
rough years of the united states
we've done an awful lot of good and we
also fought a civil war to end slavery
and as far as i know we're the quickest
country to ever eliminate slavery that
had it
and we've given opportunity and all the
things that you all know we've done it
pretty right in the united states
but we seem to be saying that is now up
for debate and we're going to just
destroy
all of the norms but it's not just the
norms
about looking at our history through a
correct lens
like it's it's not just like oh the 1619
project is right and america was founded
on savory and
evil which even the people who created
uh the 1619 project are now saying it
wasn't totally fact-based
it's more that our norms of how we
behave with each other
are starting to crumble um so i'm going
to show you a video
about 30 seconds of video where black
lives
matter protesters go to a dc
restaurant and in effect they make the
patrons of the restaurant
forum simon says this is beyond
ridiculous i don't think i can offer it
any other commentary than that so
let's go to the videotape
[Applause]
but please
[Applause]
[Applause]
police violence
thank you for your cooperation
do i need to say anything else do i need
to add commentary to that video
um imagine you're out for dinner
you're out with your wife your husband
your friend your child
you're having a burger grabbing a steak
maybe a salad
maybe wings i know that andrew cuomo the
governor of new york says that wings
aren't a meal but maybe you're having
wings for dinner i believe that wings
are a meal the fact that the governor of
new york has even had to issue a
statement telling us what food or
is or isn't a meal uh is part of a much
bigger problem
but you're out to dinner now of course
you're not inside a restaurant because
you go inside a restaurant uh you could
be killed we'll get to that story in
just a second
but you're sitting outside and then a
bunch of people come by now it does not
matter if these people are well
intentioned or not it does not matter
whether these people are right or not
the idea that people are now walking
down streets
to interrupt people from having dinner
or doing whatever private thing that
they're doing and by the way it's not
just when people are having dinner we're
seeing people stop cars in the middle of
streets
uh we're seeing people throw things at
people
and block traffic and just the litany of
things that we all know
is going on right now um so when i say
that society is having some
disintegration problem
that's the example of it because put
aside that these people that are
following the orders you're at dinner
next thing you know someone shows up and
you start behaving the way they want you
to pay jump monkey jump up and down
like no have a little bit of
self-respect have a have a little bit of
a little bit of belief in yourself or or
something about your own autonomy or
something it's just gross
but putting aside the people that were
there that just wanted to have dinner
that then feel this awful pressure
because they don't want to be called
racist and they don't want to be
put in a viral video and the rest of it
although they all got put in a viral
video
the idea that because you feel something
about black lives matter or you feel
whatever it is that you feel
that you have the right to then start
yelling at people and demanding they
jump up and down and say what you want
and interrupt people from living their
lives that
is a disintegration of society that i'm
in a weird way i'm more worried about
than all of the political craziness
because
we don't really have much of anything
that will
that will keep a sort of national
cohesion together if at the very least
we can't let people go out to dinner we
can't let people play basketball we
can't let
people do some casual things that have
nothing to do with this and if you're
walking around
thinking that your cause is so just and
so
right that you get to do whatever you
want and interrupt people
however you want you may have seen this
video that also went viral of
of a woman screaming at a bunch of white
people on a plane about how she's the
queen and the days of white privilege
are over and it was like
congratulations lady you just created a
lot of trump supporters right there
beyond making a fool of yourself and
everything else and there's so many
instances of this where the basic things
that we all thought were okay that you
could go to a restaurant that you could
get on a plane that politics wasn't
everywhere and that people weren't going
to be
fighting with you all over the place
those things seem to be disintegrated
we've got
to come back from this and i think it
starts with having a little self-respect
so i know that that story in and of
itself
isn't like the the craziest thing but i
thought it was worth addressing
um because if you are somewhere having
wings for dinner um
don't don't listen to people who show up
and make you jump up and down and repeat
after them that's what the bad guys do
they're they think they're the good guys
but most bad guys usually do
think they're the good guys right and
that that is the problem there
uh so an offshoot of that story which
will get us to our
third story of the day is that uh dr
fauci
who's basically been the sort of
public-facing
face of the covid response from the
administration
is now saying that the u.s won't get
back to normal
until late 2021. so before i read his
statement i just want to back up a
little bit
and you may remember this was probably
around
april may or so when suddenly
we went from oh we had the month where
we had to flatten the curve that's what
we were told we had to flatten the curve
and we basically flattened the curve
everywhere um and then and then they
said well then everything will open up
again
and then we'll get to herd immunity
because some people will get sick and
some people will be resistant and
hopefully we'll find a vaccine
and all of this and i remember very
specifically there was a day
when there started to be this rumor
floating around that in california the
governor our our wonderful emperor gavin
newsom
and our mayor here in la eric garcetti
they were saying no the lockdowns are
going to have to go
till august 1st august 1st and people
were like no that's never going to
happen no one will stand for it
and i remember thinking well they
probably are going to stand for it and
they'll probably just let it roll right
past august 1st and yes of course it did
roll past
august 1st and i don't know if you know
this but we're now in september let me
read this statement by fouchy because
it really is something and i think it
gets to the heart of what's wrong here
fauci says but by the time you mobilize
the distribution of the vaccine and get
a majority
or more of the population vaccinated and
protected
that's likely not going to happen until
the end of 2021. if you're talking about
getting back to a degree of normality
prior to kovid
it's going to be well into 2021 towards
the end
of 2021 so he's not talking about
flattening the curve anymore
we're talking about things about the
majority or more of people being
vaccinated
we can talk about vaccines in a
different show altogether
uh but this is just this is if we were
in a war right now and in a certain way
we are in a war with cobit and with
with the lockdowns this is what you call
mission creep you get us into a
situation here
and then suddenly we're very very
different we're in a very different
place
than we were in before all this happened
and next thing you know you still can't
go to the movies
and you're maybe can go to a restaurant
but what's going to happen to you at the
restaurant a bunch of well-meaning
people are going to make you do simon
says we're in a weird spot people that's
why i'm doing this show to hopefully
give you a little sanity hopefully i
gave you a little something
a little something to think about uh and
reminder you can watch all of these
videos right here on the youtube
or on the blaze website and we've got
more we're doing this
live now every tuesday wednesday and
thursday at 11 a.m pacific
that's 2 p.m eastern and we're going to
add some post-debate shows and a whole
bunch of other stuff
and let me know your thoughts in the
comments
right down below have a good day
you